>>Narrator: This short documentary
by a San Fernando Valley High School
student portrays the stark reality
of growing up in his
neighborhood north of Los Angeles.
>>Student: This one right
here, this is my house.
About two years ago
there was a drive-by.
I was playing out with
my little brother
and they were shooting the
bullets from this point
out to the building over there.
You can still see the
bullet hole by the window.
>>Student: See if you could
get a little bit of the tree.
>>Narrator: But these days, thanks
to a unique video-production class,
the shooting at San Fernando High
School involves video cameras,
and when students hang on the
street corner after school,
they're often outside
their teacher's house,
tapping into his wireless
Web connection on his laptop.
>>Student: That's cool.
You actually get a signal.
>>Narrator: The program that has made
a dramatic difference in the lives
of hundreds of San Fernando
High School students is housed
in Room 307, the Computer
Inspiration Studio.
>>Student: So I'm going to save it,
and now let's just say I'm going
to make some more pages here.
>>Narrator: Here, students can take
fifth- and sixth-period classes
in everything from Web site
design to video editing.
They also spend time here after
school and on weekends working
on digital projects for core classes
like social studies and economics.
>>Student: We're going
to have extracurricular going
up, and that can be blurred.
>>Narrator: The program, which
now includes some 100 members
of the San Fernando education
technology team, started in 1999
in a janitorial closet with
three students, one laptop
and a social studies
teacher named Marco Torres.
>>Marco: In fact, we
have a camera now.
You guys can go out and shoot.
>>If I look back at my own education,
I remember the projects I made.
I remember the hand I
made in kindergarten,
you know, in the plaster.
I remember the volcano
I made in third grade.
I remember the games I
won as a baseball player,
because they were projects.
They were things that had an
end to them, something tangible,
something that I can say
to my mom, "Mommy, look.
Look what I did."
>>Student: The main page.
>>Student: The main
page colors and...
>>Marco: And I know it's important,
so when I do projects for kids,
I try to give them some
insight that has meaning.
It's not just disconnected
information.
I mean, for me as a teacher
it's my moral obligation
to make information
real and connected,
and if I'm not doing that,
then I'm not teaching.
>>What's our plan?
>>Narrator: Torres' students have
already produced some 200 digital
movies, which stream over the Web
site the technology team created.
Team members also volunteer to
teach other students, teachers
and community members in free
Saturday-morning computer classes.
"Mi Barrio" Producer Cesar
Larios, who graduated last year,
volunteers at the school, passing
out to others the knowledge
he gained here.
>>Cesar: We all have to work
together in order to get ahead,
so when I learned something, it's
my duty to go and help somebody else
to learn it, and then that
person will pass that knowledge
to another person, and we'll
continue until everybody knows it.
So, that's really critical,
working together.
>>Student: This will record, right?
>>Student: Yeah, just like...
>>Student: [screams] kind of thing?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Student: All right.
>>Student: You'll have to
sacrifice yourself for the team.
>>Student: All right.
Just like...
>>Narrator: In addition to
picking up technical skills,
students learn lifelong skills
in the collaborative process,
working in small teams to help
complete each other's video.
>>Student: That's better.
I got to see your face there.
>>Student: And obviously in the
future if you get a job you're going
to have to learn to work with
people, and this is a place
where you can actually get to learn
to work with people, because you get
in groups and you know you
have to push each other
to get that done in time.
>>I've been working on all year long.
>>Rubin: This part, I'm working
on this project, I received a lot
of leadership skills being in
charge of all the deadlines
and making sure everybody did
their work, put in the committees
and just tell them what
parts to do of the movie,
and also just by working
on this program you learn
mathematical skills,
like you have to know all the
rotation of all the different axes,
just in case you want to
move the snowman 90 degrees.
>>Elizabeth: Since we all took parts
in doing little things, I did a sled
and carpet and stuff like that, and
it actually takes a lot of time,
but since there's a lot of
us it goes pretty quick.
>>Narrator: While the projects
range from comical animated shorts
to serious documentaries,
they all conform to a set
of production standards
and assessment rubrics
that Torres calls the "four P's."
>>Marco: The first P is planning,
most critical part, and the planning,
that's where kids write things
like the script, a timeline,
storyboards, very, very important.
I must be able, as a teacher, to
sit down and visualize what it is
that they're trying to do
before I hand them a camera.
>>Student: Every time I shot the
shot that I wanted in my storyboard,
I would cross it out,
and I had a storyboard
that this was 20 pages long,
and then I'd go crossing out
and you'd see progress going on.
>>Marco: The second P is production.
That's when the kids go out
and either shoot or start
to collect the information
needed to do the project.
>>Student: We could actually
get a far shot of it.
That way we get the
[inaudible] and the trees.
>>Student: The shadow and we get the
whole trees and we get the whole...
>>Marco: The third part
is the presentation.
This is when they actually
present the information.
>>Student: The style
is very important.
>>Marco: And then the
final P is assessment.
I call it "assessing with
a silent P," and assessing
with a silent P involves
the kids to develop rubrics.
What does it mean to
have a good project?
>>Student: Good evening.
This is Carmen [speaking
Spanish] Cruz-Diaz,
and I'm reporting live
from Channel 307.
>>I think it's the movie
that I'm most proud of,
because it's my first movie that
I got to direct and film and edit
and use a green screen in, so
that's the best movie, I think.
>>Student: Where have
I seen this before?
>>Student: Obviously I'm
learning, because I look back at,
"I could've used a different shot for
that," or, "I could've done this,"
but the best thing is, you know,
go on and make another movie
and then just, you
know, make it better.
>>Narrator: Of the videos
students have done to date,
none has had a greater impact
than the documentary
Consuelo Molina produced
as a project for an economics class.
>>Marco: She wanted to talk
about some of the consequences
of the world economy and the protests
that were happening in Washington,
Seattle, around the
World Trade Organization,
so she decided to focus
on sweatshops.
She knew that if she had done
this project traditionally,
in front of a class, the information
would've died there in the class.
And she took this documentary
and posted it on the Web,
and several people have found it.
The Women's Human Rights
Conference in Paris saw it
and asked her permission to show it.
And other places like in India,
there was a teacher who asked
if he could show it at
this national conference.
>>Consuelo: It's a
big issue, but, yeah,
at the same time it's a high
school project, so I don't think --
I wouldn't have thought
that people from Australia
or different people would've
reacted to it the way they did.
I guess a little voice
can make a big impact.
>>Marco: This is a connection
that I'm looking for.
This is that bridge,
the digital divide.
>>Click on that for me.
>>Student: This one?
>>Marco: Yeah.
>>And the more I can create
opportunities for relevancy,
the more connections are made, the
brighter our hope light shines.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.